Bladesmiths, congratulations.
You fellas have made
it into the final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history,
General George
Washington's lion-headed
cuttoe Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
TYLER: So my billet's going to
be made out of 1084 and 15N20.
Really good contrasting
steels for Damascus.
The last time I did my sabre
build for the army episode,
I went with the Damascus.
The Damascus, it is a
risk because there's
multiple things that could
go wrong, from cold shots
to stress fractures.
But as long as my blade does
perform as I expect it to,
my Damascus is going
to be that thing
that puts me over the top.
GENE: Here we are again back
in Springfield, Virginia,
at my home forge.
The plan for today is to cut
out a billet for the sword.
Well, this wood anvil, as they
call it, or the log [inaudible]
method to put a gentle
arc in the blade.
That's the same log that I
used for the Mameluke sword
for the Marine competition.
It worked before.
If it's not broken,
don't fix it.
TYLER: Day two.
I got to get this
blade quenched today,
and I'm going to
make some changes
to the way I do it in my forge.
I'm going to try
using the tube method.
The main goal is
to take this tube
and just turn it into
a nice long, hot oven.
Had a little bit of issues
getting even heat last time.
So I think with that tube
it should give me a nice,
more even, controlled heat.
I don't hear any cracks,
pings, or anything like that.
I nailed it.
It's exactly what
I need it to be.
[banjo]
Anyway.
Day four finally here.
I'm feeling ready.
I have a plan, and I have
some hurdles to get over.
The biggest one [inaudible]
is that lion-head pommel.
First thing this
morning, I'm going
to put that thing in plaster
of Paris and let it set.
Wonder if I should
do it with pewter?
You don't have to get
pewter nearly as hot.
It will be shiny and
look just like silver.
It looks like garbage.
I think I'm going to go with
the silver one just because
of the look of the silver.
Right now I need to
finish the lion head,
polish everything,
and sharpen the blade,
try to take some weight off
anywhere that I possibly can,
and then put it all together.
Woo!
Done.
It's done.
Dave four, final day.
I've never carved
a pommel before,
so I don't know how
long it's going to take,
and I'm going to have to
put some time into it.
So I'm just profiling
from one way right now
the shape of the lion's head
to kind of refine it to what
my final shape is going to be.
And then I start removing some
more material, a little fine
tuning with my rotary tool.
It pretty much looks
like a lion to me.
All right, veterans,
welcome to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your weapon
and deliver killing
blows to this pig carcass.
Tyler, you're up first.
Ready?
[laughter]
I'm ready.
[music playing]
All right, Tyler, your handle
construction, just right.
Your edge is very sharp.
Overall, sir, this
sabre will kill.
Perfect.
All right, Gene,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Let's do this, Doug.
[music playing]
All right, Gene,
this is a heavy sword
and very forward heavy.
But when you have a forward
heavy blade that you're hitting
that meets resistance,
a cylindrical, almost
circular handle makes
it twist in my hand.
So probably there's a reason
why the chain came off.
But your blade is sharp.
It will kill.
All right, gentlemen, December
25, 1776, George Washington
leads the Continental Army
across a frozen Delaware River
to attack the Hessians
at Trenton, New Jersey.
And he probably didn't chip
his way through the ice,
but that's not going to
keep us from our strength
test, the ice-block chop.
Tyler, you're up first.
Are you ready?
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, so Tyler,
your chain fell off,
but there's no
damage on your edge.
Your handle's comfortable.
Other than the
chain, you nailed it.
Thanks.
Good job.
All right, Gene.
Do it.
[laughter]
[music playing]
All right, Gene,
your blade's edge
is still there and still sharp.
The issue is the rest
of your chain fell off,
and it's picked up a bend.
I have less issue with
that and more issue
with this polished handle.
It's just hard to hold on to.
But it is strong, and it does
have an edge, so good job.
Oorah.
All right, veterans,
our sharpness test today
is the Hessian charge.
This is all about what your
edge will do to these dummies.
Tyler, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yep.
[music playing]
All right, Tyler, the
weight of your weapon
does prevent me from
going very fast,
but you have a very sharp
edge all the way through.
Your weapon, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Gene,
it's your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Let's do this, Doug.
[music playing]
All right, Gene, to be able
to maintain a good grip on this,
more of the cuts
I create are more
impact as opposed
to a slash where
it cuts all the way through.
So you have some
cuts here that are
more nicks, deep nicks, because
you have a very sharp edge.
And for this test, sir,
your weapon will cut.
Awesome.
Tyler, Gene, first
of all, I want to thank
you both for your service.
You're both
champions in my mind.
You've already won
your branch divisions,
but there can only be one
Battle of the Branches champion,
and you'll walk out of here
with a check for $50,000.
And that champion is Tyler.
Congratulations.
You are the Battle
of the Branches
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Gene, please
surrender your blade.
There's a lot of
Marines out there,
and there's a lot of great
guys in the Marine Corps.
And so for me to stand
here and represent
them is pretty humbling.
I learned too that
it's not about just
the metal being forged in fire.
I feel like I've
been forged in fire.
And it's how you handle the ups
and downs, the wins and losses,
and it will determine real
quick how you've been heat
treated throughout your life.
Tyler, congratulations.
You overcame every obstacle
set in front of you.
You beat out all
the other smiths,
and now you're the
Battle of the Branches
"Forged in Fire" champion.
That's a title that comes with
a check for $50,000 and, most
importantly, bragging rights.
Good job, my brother.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
I'm super excited.
When this whole thing
started, I had no idea how
it was all going to turn out.
It feels good to have
represented the Army.
The fact that I just won
$50,000 is starting to set in.
I'm Sergeant Tyler Hackbarth,
and I'm the new Battle
of the Branches champion.